[Music] you ready yeah I'm ready Purge Anarchy
I was legitimately trying to fix my shirt I
hate you really hard on that one if you thought
you weren't going to be Purge for Purge Anarchy
then you had another thing coming I think I
might have pooped my pants a little bit and
it wasn't even scary oh Tara how I've missed
you we're back for another Purge we're doing
it man I'm ready we are back because you guys
liked us and we love that so don't forget like
this video comment subcribe ring the bell
ring the bell I'm really starting to love it
she didn't love it before but now I'm getting
her in it I got to shove me in people's faces
and eventually they go I think I like it that's
what she said we are here for Redemption today
actually though because both Tara and I said
that we were Pro Purge in the last video we
are no longer Pro Purge we're just Pro The Purge
franchise so we're back for the second one and
if you guys want to be back in the biggest
way possible go over to patreon so you can
have your full length Reaction watch along where
you sync up with your own copy that's the super
sexy rejects only baby wow and you get a dance
which is very cool if you guys were wondering if
Greg was off to the side eating a pen right now
he is but also Greg and John cover shows over
there exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included what are we purging today
negative energy oh oh oh people who don't like
Halloween stuff be gone get out of here let's do
this so we don't know who's in this we don't
know if it's the same cast or different cast
I know nothing about this one I mean I didn't
know anything about the first one but yeah what
does anarchy make you think like the first
much more Anarchy we could get with people
just going off on their own killing people but
can I tell you something yeah I plan on being
the Anarchy of this movie [Laughter] per okay oh
wow3 which is this year unemployment is below 5%
crime is virtually non-existent while every
year fewer and fewer people live below the
poverty line all thanks to the perge The Purge
so this is the point in time where I believed
that people were good last movie now we know
they're not they're not they're they're taking
out lowincome communities March 21st that's my
friend's birthday oo hey friend all right we
only have 2 hours 26 minutes till the start
of the purge all right how are we prepping
do we still got security stuff or is everybody
just like giving up and they're like just blue
flowers all day long how is everything Mr saan
great as always good you get home now Eva it's
getting late stay safe kind of recognize her it's
my thing to not know where people are from though
it'll soon be a war out there prognosticator estim
Sap's gone that's it what is she waiting for why
does this [__] let us go Eva oh you to ride
home I'm fine Carlos if he has to take me home
I'd accept that ride girl he's a dog I like
that dog I would walk the [__] out of that
dog you're disgusting it's true the dialogue
in this is pretty natural I can't even lie
you're really going to ask her tonight I have
to I can't afford his medicine much longer
this country it's crazy Even in our the fake
good world yeah insulin is that what we think
yeah like what's the next most expensive
Med for a kid it's not going to be ater
all Frank gillo I like him yeah he's dop
he's a cute man too did you see him in the
oh no what's the show that was on peacock
um the guy who thought that his life was
a movie and oh um uh something P something
whatever Frank Grill in that he's a smoke
showell I love him from um lights
and his name is we don't know he's
also currently in the Fall of the House of
Usher literally look like Taylor Swift yeah why
is he what are you looking at going through their
nothing old stuff you about to break up with her
what's he doing our regime was voted into office
n years ago and the first order of business with
the Epic of crime just straight up weird heyart
how you doing how you doing you don't need for
protection tonight Etta look on a cheap Che or
a blade to cut your man throat whatever you need
we take any kind of payment I would buy a blade
I wonder if she already just for dayto day also
they don't need a day-to-day one that's the whole
thing about The Purge take me up there with you
tonight get little protection you know what I'm
saying come on now you want no thanks dieo I'm
the man for the job he plays a good drunk guy
we no longer worship at the alar of Christ this
guy Muhammad Yahweh also famous I saw his protest
posters all around the neighborhood he lives
here Papa he's just like us the purge is not
about containing crime to one night and cleansing
our souls but it's about one thing money yeah we
can't afford to protect ourselves that's enough I
can't listen this crap he's as full of [__] as
they are he's not he is right he's really not I'm
going to take a long nap and don't bother me going
to try to sleep through this godforsaken holiday
so weird calling it a holiday yeah I'm sorry I'm
so grumpy girls I hate this night forgive me I
love his voice so last time we started with a rich
family this time we're not now we're the opposite
yeah I'll take care of my room like boarded up
he's old you're going to let him take care I'd be
like no man let it I'll board up your room how did
things go with Mrs Crawley well did you at least
make a good argument did you say everything that
we practiced she said nothing sorry baby maybe is
just trying to hold this family together I said I
want to tell your I I heard you cuz as soon as
you say it out loud to another person then it's
irreversible maybe she's pregnant oh they're or
they're breaking up and that's why he was looking
at can you unlock the car please it's unlocked
no it's not there okay perch God that scared
me uh aren't you a little bit early to be puron
yeah he can't do anything yet he's just like
marking them I don't know all right taunting is
a lot loud prior I would not like that oh that's
spooky I'd walk around with a
barbed wire jacket and barbed
wire leggings yes Roxy I said it bar [Laughter]
guns it these guys would be like no I'm not
going to taunt her like barb wire man we don't
have a whole lot of time before commencement
Shane all right we we'll be fine no problems
you won't be fine I see the sun setting sir
also I'd cover everything I have in like blue
flowers I'd want to be with Frank during this
time oh yeah he's got all the weapons but blue
flowers doesn't mean they can't attack you
it just means you're Pro the holiday right
but I still would be like Oh I'm Pro also don't
mess with me you can't go out there you know how
dangerous it is go you need to leave he's going
to protect people seems like it don't do this it
won't make you feel any better he lost somebody
last year go with you know husband and your new
family so that's his ex that clearly something
happened last year now he goes out and he does
this and helps but she has a new family he seemes
military the way he's putting his guns together
he's got all his weapons he's like maybe he's
just a guy who knows guns I don't know we must
pick up arms this year we will fight back I'm
like yeah that does make sense I guess if the
poor just gained had a lot of weapons right
to defend themselves then maybe they wouldn't
be taken out but I'm also like well how do
they afford to get those weapons to defend
themselves what's happening here why does he
have a limo just say you changed your mind
not that we didn't come to a joint decision
this is the EXA you think it's a breakup I
feel like it is right exactly why we need
to tell your sister that we're separating
yeah tire blew out not going to make it
you said you were we all knew it pull
put something on the car I think this is
like the second meet cute they were going
to get separated and now it's all going
to go to [__] they're going to be like
we're going to get married and have
children now I would be go home for
like four days before The Purge just to make
you're not going anywhere right yeah start
running so their grandfather left just in case
in a limo and that's why I'm confused cuz why
is she working at a diner to get him medication
and he can get somebody sent him the limo that's
what when they said and he's like I'm in a weird
mood obviously he knew something that was going
down oh
[__] wow h no thanks I
jump over the bridge I don't
know wow Purge oh God you're like a fortress
you can't Purge a purger you know a fortress
maybe if you had a pillow News 13 Wishes anyone
who is not participating in this year's Purge a
safe evening oh ho ho I know her too Amy
paffrath oh wow good you good job on the
name this is your emergency broadcast system
announcing the commencement of the annual Purge
sanctioned by the US government of class 4 and
lower have been authorized for use during The
Purge all other weapons are restricted what
are other weapons like bombs and Emergency
Medical Services will be unavailable until
tomorrow morning at 7 a.m. God maybe don't
be terrifying hide yeah like I wouldn't be in
the middle of street I don't understand how
people would go out to get to do an errand and
not take a weapon with them on the day of the
purge he might have something with him I hope
so nothing more than a knife I don't think but
[Music] what this is oh my God they just
hunt people this is terrifying it's so
smart of them to have it start at sundown
visually just like that we were in the light
for this whole time it turns The Purge and
we're in the darkness waiting for the light
yes yeah the way that these movies are shot
you just feel effing petrified I agree I mean
especially the way they use like the handheld
and the and the angles in it it's like it's
great but so why does that why oh my
goodness I was wondering if this dumb
guy in the truck would be like oh they
look like they're going to purge if they
look similar would he yeah I thought maybe
that yeah I don't know and why would they
if they know people do that why would they
just be out walking I assumed everyone who
has like a gun and looks like they're purging
doesn't mess with other purgers is what I a
Callum okay well he didn't protect that
person this is ter I like everything now
that they're taking us out into the world to
show us I find it even scarier yes so smart
that the first one were contained yeah so we did
second one now we're seeing it [Music] all start
looking for weapons break that piece of wood I
was just thinking that I feel like somebody's
in there trash can oh yeah he's smart get the
other one get the other one he said let's just
get out of here like what okay [__] it's
them we got to move we got to move we got to
move this is the worst game of hide and seek
ever ever mom what what is it mom come here
oh my God I am not a fortress dear stepen
Kelly my greatest heartache is seeing the
two girls I love so much struggling in this
world I'll be a martyr for a wealthy family
tonight they paid me for this service
$100,000 will be transferred into your
account how much only 100,000 live a
safe life oh my god oh oh my God this
is I'm sick this makes me feel like in my
stomach like that my stomach try to find I
mean it's it's not going to be of any use
if these guys just plan on cutting him up
it's how the wealthy Purge B baby they buy
poor and sick people and they take them into
their homes and they kill them where they're
safe we can do something about this I don't
know what but we can still do something about
stop he's gone that's devastating it's really
terrible there's something so wrong with people
that like that's so believable yeah that I'm
like oh yeah it's all these richs I'm like you
already have everything you have everything you
need to survive in a world and not struggle and
yet you're like on Purge night we would like to
kill people it's so mess stop it makes me mad
yeah I this movie like brings up like what is
this who are they it looks like an army I
have no idea oh maybe it's the drunk guy
coming to protect them who yeah oh going
to protect you protect you from me oh no
what Frank Grilla what are you going to do who
are you here to help what he hasn't helped any
one yet oh my God who don't you know that you got
to be polite to people in this Society Diego don't
come back here we have guns and we will shoot
you really I got a little bonus got a little
package deal e you better prepare yourself
tonight cuz tonight it's mother our [__]
it's my night to Mother bur okay y'all need to
guide him towards the window and then throw him
out of it where is Frank Grilla ah oh no oh no
this skateboarding mother please leave alone it
please what's that throw him out of the
window is that your father please please
get it girl oh gross oh my God I can't get
the gun somebody come on now you want them
to come and get it where you oh good he's just
going to get himself killed I love it thank God
oh my God these are like professional
purgers like how many years have purging
cuz they look like freaking a SWAT team oh
no they're about to get purged no now you're
screwed let's bring these two downstairs Big Daddy
we have two for your personal Purge oh [__]
that's it come on Frank oh I can't wait for come
on Frank come on Frank yes Frank in the Batmobile
yeah hold on bulletproof fireproof oh no that was
like a stunt person that was a great stunt Frank
what's your move here Frank just drive just drive
just drive yeah he can't he's going to he's saying
just drive like don't don't help them but he can't
help it he has to help them Callie F heard that
so is they're all in like protective gear they're
going to be hard to kill yeah but Frank gillow is
no I mean nobody's a match for him he's a pro
you're right he's probably like an army dude
maybe he's a seal like a sniper please don't let
him be a bad guy is he going to get his carcked
all oh no by the kids they right behind us oh my
God they're going to steal his car they're going
to steal his car oh my gosh [__] I knew it oh
my God Frank's then going to be out here is all
of his weapons in the I hate all of it kill him
let's go Frank yes yes yes yes John Wicked that
[__] yeah yes oh yeah you psychopath yeah you
maniac but he's getting his car taken what's
going on out there we're safe we're safe we're
in here we're good oh no they're going to get
okay he's going to get back in the car maybe
has the keys oh my God please take them come
on okay God now he's got to take care of four
people my God what is he a little full call
he's a real daddy now he's a purge Daddy
I'll tell you that much about sugar daddy
he's a purge daddy daddy I'm trying to
look for my Pur daddy Hey where's my Pur
daddy I've be lining up Purge Daddy's like
two weeks prior out of the will I will oh
God don't shoot get out of the oh I knew it
this little shut up hands up and shut your
mouth hands up and shut your mouth I feel
like that car bullets can't get through
it ah ah here we have it over there too Co
please where do you want him to go because
it can come from any angle this time this
movie is just so much more like the other
one was intense for different reasons but this
is just Anarchy this is anarchy we didn't know
where it would go and now we do yeah see
wow him with the American flag on his hat
he's so effing he is like so ready to purge
every year what was that Army doing in your
building why were they after you why would they
after you I know why are you in the streets our
car just broke down our car broke down we don't
want to hurt anybody are you armed no no what
were you doing outside yeah saving your life
I go out there to help people I'm The Purge
Daddy I don't know why he talks like that I
made him talk like oh no oh this can't help
anybody else sir where are we going he doesn't
have the answers God damn another car car what
I thought he had like an indestructible vehicle
maybe nowhere what' he say nowhere yeah I think
that's what he said cuz he knows it's I bet you
has enough weapons to give all of them and then
they got to fight him I mean obviously the tire
is going to blow out when he's getting shot at
or engine yeah there that's what were we in this
alley no he must have put a neutral and pushed it
I guess you're on your own now huh wait what
you should have never gotten involved in Son
of my business okay but you did so it is your
business now no it's not it's loaded take it
take it well at least he gave him a weapon he's
giv you a weapon yes yes girl you be so grateful
he saved your lives I'm not enjoying these what
she's saying can't take you with me you'll slow
me down we won't slow you down so you're really
just going to leave us here he gave you a weapon
dude why did you save us if you just going to
leave us here would die please help us wait I
I can get you a car yeah offer something I I have
a friend in the city not far if you get us there
safely you can take her car and do what you have
to do where she live D and Bryan she's smart make
sure love it love it this woman this girl better
say yes when she calls her I know right y can my
friend over your car you the answer bettering
be yes I I'll explain when I get there okay
what are you looking for Sniper right that guy
in that roof remember she lives with her parents
they're happy to have us if you can get us to her
place safely the car is yours can she help us too
you're useless yeah she really I don't I I really
I'm not trying to be a [__] but she's useless
she was like you're giving us a gun to what I
say you stay close you slow me down I cut you
all loose yeah yeah yeah understood yes sir Purge
daddy why is he literally the hottest man on the
Planet a virus oh control the masses
nourish and flish he's going to have
to kill this guy I think he's a woman I am
a one woman you're all in my PA oh my God
M9 silver TI Auto Magnum the right arm of
the Free World and the left hand of God y
[__] be crazy she's nuts I was just trying
to make out what the heck she was saying and
now I'm no thanks the sound design on this
every single gunshot feels like it's hitting
me it's like all a jump scare and I also like
how a lot of the lighting they play with it's
all pink and blue which I really it's draws my
eyes in I love it usually with the Shadows it's
just that gray black but they really do they have
some color Pops in here which really nice we're
going to cross Banks no no no that's a long way
it's going to be much quicker if we go down here
no don't do that oh what was that oh my God it's
a trap what you're going to what going to shoot it
what okay holy junk shoot the cable oh d d d oh my
God come on y'all he gave you a gun help him out I
can't believe how useless Matt s and his partner
are yeah it's terrible he's telling you to shoot
it sh shoot a trap why are you guys not shooting
the Trap come on man shoot he's saying shoot the
Trap okay you got it oh great now we have all
these people after us I I honestly can't get
over how moronic those two are they really are I'm
not saying I would be better he's a littleit he at
least he at least shot the Trap after like seven
times I'm Liz and this is a shame AA my daughter
C Li Shane Ava c doing intros okay is anyone else
kind of curious about this guy I'm just glad that
he's out here with us yeah me too but we all got
stuck out here and he chose to be that means he's
purging dude he saved your lives he told you
he saved Our Lives all I'm saying is that he's
out here armed to the teeth on purite voluntarily
means he's trying to do something nasty I can hear
you yeah he's like right there you dumb dumb he
gave you one of his weapons you idiot brought us
out of the movie making because it's just like you
know in movies where nobody can hear whispering go
hey step over here and they're 2 ft away as if
nobody can hear what they're saying what's your
name you're good with guns I'm guessing you're
either a cop or a criminal and I'm guessing you're
either a pain in my ass or a pain in my ass Callie
you got to chill what are you going to do stop
you shut up all of you shut up yeah I'm going to
stop talking because you're being an [__] okay
not because you told me to shut up you don't bite
the hand that feeds you in this scenario come on
like oh no oh no what's the red light oh oh what
that here hangs stock broker David newat still on
pensions now he's gone wow I bet you that would
happen all over town yeah is that tear gas smoke
canister we were just doing our duty oh my God
look at his uniform this is one of the bastards
who came into our building they're just doing
their Duty yall need to start taking off their
yeah totally putting it on immediately yeah but
they're useless so they won't go check the cab see
if this thing's working stay alert stay alert
go ahead go go all right Callie what are you
going to do that's awesome look at this they're
accessing the city's traffic camps traffic camps
are controlled by the government how did they get
into these I mean who are these people maybe you
just answered your own question yep government
is that your building yeah but why is it all red
you're being targeted for something along with
all these other buildings here here all over
the city huh maybe you're right cie look I'm
telling you this is the new founding fathers
the trucks no good no the engine's all blown
out or something okay Shane delivering more
bad news that's Carmela's Mark mom I told Papa
he was the real deal his group took these out
oh no oh no God y'all should yeah exactly grab a
weapon and grab a vest oh no oh God I hate it oh
god oh
boy oh my God I don't like it the knife
stab sound you guys going to take the
subway that would be awesome is
it working oh it's a rat do not
say anything you [__] yeah not oh my go
she's gonna literally shut the up here we
go you at a restaurant that's gross oh nice
loving this choke out right now cuz they can't
do guns or everybody will come has nobody else
had to kill somebody else it's just you Frank
goow I correct cuz they well they had guns
right there earlier no nobody did anything
with them so I kind of like their relationship
though Callie and Frank why'd you help us we
establish a no talking Rule people are getting
killed all over the city why did you stop for
us cie is me I can't stop asking questions we
were putting up a hell of a fight he reminded
me of someone who his daughter that's what
broke him and his ex-wife up cuz she got
taken killing doesn't help anything it doesn't
heal someone enough enough go back with your
mommy he wasn't purging yeah also he saved you I
don't understand the questioning because he did
save your life but he is armed to the teeth so
she is thinking he was out to purge yeah she's
saying no matter what the reason's wrong but
you don't know that that's what he was doing
right Kelly sometimes we got to learn to
zip at us us talkative [__] yeah I mean
this guy he's a fortress he's not going to
tell you put this on I don't need that put
it on I said I said I don't need it put it on
yeah listen to H Jesus yeah from here and out
she just be yes sir Purge daddy and nothing
else I bet that thing saves her life what was
that oh no they're all scared there's no threat
they're just trying to make it through the night
oh that's so sad hey you okay I just want to get
out of here she can't breathe she's having a panic
attack or something I guess okay I'm going
to need AA to keep it together oh no oh my
God how they get cars down there oh I guess they
can fit that down the stairs and in through the
W yeah this is a whole oh God this is what
happens oh my God my God they run over his
body oh my God is running really going to
help no I mean oh my God she can't get
up and run honey even if it hurts let's
go what's happening she cannot breathe
legitimately hard to watch she having a
panic attack he's going to carry her out
he doesn't have time Eva you got to pull
it together babe you're in a vehicle we're
not going to make it okay Shane do something
I then use your gun somebody do something
okay Shane what are you doing my God we do
just shoot yeah just shoot just shoot whatever
your name is k them yeah do something useful
aim for the head aim for the head head shot
come on now you got shot in the arm come on
now oh my God I'm F I'm F I'm F just
keep shooting yeah keep shooting yeah
just forget about him come on girl you
were going to leave him anyway yeah oh
exactly oh yeah get him get him come on
get a head shot yes that is so satisfying
yes okay all right yes Redemption is yours
redeemed yourself you're bleeding I cut it
on the platform it's fine we'll help you
just tell us I said it's fine okay Frank
he's been shot I have no idea how bad call
your friend all right we're close we're
going to get him up Frank's also bleeding
but nobody yeah there are 4 hours and 30
minutes remaining in this year's Purge so
how many hours are there 12 I guess I don't
remember oh no oh great yeah we remember the
government's utilizing the cameras yeah we have
a Target match on the civilians Who attack Truck
2 oh no oh great Target match whoa and they come
in semis yeah we saw oh right cuz it's a gar
I got it yeah this just looks bigger from up
above gr shot no oh no Talia let us in Talia
Talia let us in bro you guys look like hell
come on come on hurry up girl we've been out
during Purge Night oh no she's going to end
up dead for helping it's going to be [Music]
sad I can't believe you guys went through all
that stuff it's just insane she's drinking wine
and she looks like she's just relaxing come on
everybody eat drink yes I recommend drinking
it's the best way to get through the evening
oh no but the government's coming here right
now yeah they're about to break through what
about you tough guy want to drink no thanks okay
you're really going back out there somewhere I
have to be my father and my brother-in-law he need
a super they were just checking the building don't
mind my husband's clothes he's not purging he
just thought it was a crazy idea to go out and
see what's happening tonight wait I don't know
what the hell I was thinking thank God he came
to his senses I mean look at him he would have
been the laughing stock of the neighborhood oh
no is there some sneaky business that's about
to go down building's locked down and good you
had a rough go over it my friend yeah relax make
yourself at home you're safe here oh no anything
else you need just ask I could use a clean shirt
down the hall second door on the left top drawer
of the bureau what's mine is yours it's very nice
I feel like it's also an excuse used to like look
around I don't know he must be going somewhere
where he needs to be in a clean shirt what is
your theory on where he's going I feel like
he needs to well maybe just might just need a
shirt but I'm also to take care of his wound yeah
he's going to find something right like it has
oh she knows that the government's coming or
something what's happening she gave a weird
look like she wants to Purge or like I
don't know she could think of a couple
scenarios does it hurt as much as
the heartache scared the [__]
out of me this is their meute their second
they're G to fall back in love [Laughter]
perh I don't know how that works always on me
sad actually it's my favorite I think you do
it for me sorry I got a shot oh are you going
to use this excuse for the rest of our life a
let's change the atmosphere up in here no more
person I got peret in my system and red wine I
feel like it's Xanax but okay come on oh this
sister she's not going to like it why are you
fluttering with her husband your friend likes
to drink and she's taking pills back there yeah
she's pretty wild but we'll be okay line do you
care if we dance she doesn't even care she ATT
I don't know how to thank you I hope they're
in love you're going out there to kill someone
who wronged you you believe in this Knight
don't you I think you should just take care
of your daughter and I need the car make out
say I love you before he goes there is no car
she was trying to keep you safe but we needed
you and I needed the car I I did what I had to
I did it for my daughter I was doing this for
my son and I trusted you I knew it you have no
idea what you might have taken away from for me
tonight yikes please come on you're safe here oh
no oh no great here we go what's Happening Here
We Go yep oh my God holy she knows they're having
an affair so she killed them she's your sister
lorine what are you doing I read all your emails
you cheating mother you both deserve to die oh
my god get back get back back up back up sorry
okay I'm sorry oh oh so let us cut this out you
this is my right granted to me by my government
yeah Frank O oh whoa Frank shot the guy to
make him let go the girl yeah he's a g great
shot oh my God this crazy lady Frank doesn't
want to kill her he's like bum that
cheating now now you guys deal with
it you've got be [__] kidding me how did they
find them how did they find them this movie is
awesome dude yeah I don't understand why it
has like a 58% rating the tension the music
the scoring the whole thing he's here I know it
and I want him he's here okay so he wants Frank
Gilla he shot me shot half my team I want him
dead Exposition yeah I was like that's the only
part that is like oh we didn't need that you can
recognize who he is is I want him dead move now
we have 30 seconds move over the fence fast now
go yeah go go useless woman isn't useless anymore
however no she just takes a little too long to do
stuff though oh no oh no oh no what oh just knew
it oh he's in a truck yeah but he's not
taken by the government government he's
taken by these people the purgers did they get
AA and her people too that's what I'm wondering
do they have all of them I'd rather be taken by
these people than the government people oh yeah
they have all they got all of them okay
why are they keeping them alive yeah like
where are they taking him why aren't they
just doing it right there how did you find
us like do they work for the government people
right I I also am curious how did they even know
the the guy with the hat know where they were
how did they know that they were even at that
building we got lucky we was roaming around
out there all night this is he's W an Oscar
why haven't you just killed us already we're not
purging tonight we don't need to kill anyone just
need money they have money they have $100,000
yeah R me my money man let's go let's do this
what are they doing oh wow did they just do that
all night capture people get paid maybe this is
where Frank wanted to be anyway maybe there
people who took his kid if you move or speak
you will be shot oh my God oh my God this is so
messed up just every element dude and what they
bid on them I bet ladies and gentlemen since this
is the last Purge of the evening the entry price
will be2 200,000 wow it's like the puru dant ball
I tried to make it work to be like a debutant ball
it didn't work the head of sists all right one
spot left anyone else they do this every year Mr
HST the music bro oh I mean it's just everything
is like perfect I hope one of these people killed
Frank grillo's kid and he kills kills him so hard
good luck we'll see you shortly on the hunting
grounds come on what the this is just so like it's
not even out of the realm of the possibility of in
my brain I just go yeah that would happen which
is so sad hunting grounds they're going to have
to run and fight it's like squid game but with
the purge oh my God are they like in a museum
they have to survive an hour right or whatever
the wow this is I mean oh my God it's like a
whole different movie all of a sudden not in a
bad way just like in like a it just keeps one
up against it's like hold my beard no hold my
beard no hold my beard now have this Martini
really interesting choice to have the people in
The Masks be people that were looking to just
get money you know I bet you they just go around
kidnap people they give them and they're just like
yeah I mean but that's why it's from the top
down like you know yeah and we see oppressed
people oppressed people we can't see we're dead
we should come back you we need you to stay just
listen to him scar coming back Callie this is
when we zip yeah and we let him lead [__] I
like I've taught you yes sir Purge daddy he's
got to take one of them down oh my God I am
sorry this is the wrong time for this he is so
sexy he is just truly so sexy to me in this in
this dim neon lighting as The Purge Daddy yeah
oh see he knows hand to hand get that weapon
nope oh yes nice nice did they see that I
think they did they look shocked oh my God
how is he going to survive this he didn't get
the gun no but he needed to get the goggles
to see or something but he didn't I don't
think I don't know some John wickness did
he get the goggles well now he got the
go hey baby get the other pair too see
all the rest of you never again yes now just
go pick off there boom boom bye yes ter Boom
Boom by as easy as Boom Boom by whoa came in
swinging yeah remember they are good with their
blades shoot them didn't he have the the gun
did he drop it I don't know D is she fit him
probably most people who get captured
and brought in here usually aren't good
Fighters because they got captured right though
they're not used to this whoa I think you just
got he's just gaining all the glasses the glasses
and then he gives it to all of them so smart oh
shoot through the window is it bulletproof of
course it is yeah you [__] that's what I'd be
yelling perch I almost just did it to you God
there's three left it's loaded you point and
you shoot why did he give it to you so's coming
light them up I guess she did was the one who
took out the ones in the in the yeah that was a
good shot I think she did it oh they're leaving
oh yeah you better leave run run little doggies
they're going to bring no they're going to bring
gas in here or something no get out of the room
what was that oh no uh here we go oh my God that's
so many people that's all right Frank Frankie
can handle them bro there's like 40 of them I
know but like maybe he can John W get out I
love you I need you to know oh wow that was
wow
what a this is like such a powerful movie do
you think anybody's going to make it out maybe
cie cie has the vest on did we forget that yeah
cie does have the vest on yeah she might be the
only one and and maybe Frank and cie because
he lost his son but he doesn't lose her right
she's the only one that I said was going to
die at the beginning now she she might make
it oh wait somebody come to help them who
who is this oh is this this is the guy on
the TV right and then the gr's going to be
like we know you that's what he look like
on the TV but maybe wait that's the guy from
the first one oh that's the military guy not
fire we're here to help you isn't it yep
yep yep what that oh my God too bad Matt
Sison didn't make it out who the are you nobody
special just some people who don't necessarily
agree with the pares all oh our guy yes See's
going to go John yep she knows the new founding
fathers W you your money and mother The Purge
I love him ah you once said that the mark of
mentality will no longer keep the American
people stunted we are outraged and we're
fighting back nice to meet you too young
lady oh that's so sweet oh my God he's very
emotional stay you hey we got to go oh no he
almost made it I want to purge what look we'll
take care of her go we got it I'm sorry get some
weapons see if they have extra she said I want to
purge that see that's how we create monsters get
ready to bleed rich [__] ass it's around time
there oh God no no don't shoot me don't Sho she
so wrong but I hope he kills her you remember me
yeah okay shoot her in the leg in the foot now
run run run come on just a little shot in the
calf or something no he won't cuz he's a good
guy that's fine all right the owner of that
house killed my son 12 months ago Nicholas was
coming home from school and he swerved off the
road oh blood alcohol level was three times
the legal limit but you know he got off on
a technicality so so it wasn't during The Purge
oh him and his wife and his two little kids well
they live in that house happily ever after two
weeks ago I came here and I disabled his back
barricade that's what we're doing here I want you
both to stay in this car do you understand me T
immediately said no no the thing is they make us
feel conflicted because they didn't kill him in
the purge they killed him because he was drunk and
that's still effing murder yeah but it's you know
that his intention was not to murder somebody
right it was an accident but also it's like
well there are you're cutting
it close no don't talk get up
no maybe he's not going to kill him I don't think
maybe he's going to like tape him took my boy you
took my took my maybe it wasn't him maybe it was
her and he covered for her you're going to pay for
what you did to me what you did to my boy she's
going to do something what the five minutes are
up whoa she killed him anyway or is this a new
person maybe he didn't kill him oh my god wow I
don't think he killed him but of course this
guy don't save lives tonight we take lives
fortunately the citizens aren't killing enough
so we supplement it all oh it's important work
the nffa does and we can't have any interference
can't have Heroes he's going to be able to shoot
him right cuz he do a gun I know I'm thinking
what happen Blessed Be America nation reborn
somebody take him out yeah there you go nice head
shot was it the guy he could cuz he didn't kill
him oh no they're under direct orders to take
the girls alive if they see them but I'm like
do they actually follow the rules they're going
to kill this guy Jesus oh you listen to that I
think so because there's cameras everywhere
facial recognition cuz I was like why would
they follow the rules now I yeah they're outside
yeah is he G to make it through this I think he's
going to survive he got a car you got a car go
get it out go okay what about the car they came
in oh yeah is it dead or something three come
on they I mean it's good he got shot now cuz
the hospitals are open right now do you think
there would be no think that other girl lived
useless oh all right she went yeah I think
they probably protected her and she was able
to I would love to go back and be like who did
she get to kill I guess is like one of the rich
people is he going to make it he's just going
to grab her hand and die don't say that per
[Music] there me a long line yeah right like I
might but they did get there just in time like
I was saying the hospital's just open like five
minutes ago they shot him a couple times right
yes you think he lived yeah what happened to
the girl with the group do we girl I think she
live too care yeah okay James demonica
Blum all right there we go my God that
kid that after the kid shooting Micha
Michael B this it have some Michael B
yeah oh my God
this H the the choice of this song to play
like during the and then the disruption of
it that's Frank gillow Love You Frank Daddy
Carmen hogo that must be the girl that Zach
Guilford that's the dude's name that was
in Friday night Friday night okay yeah
Don know Zoe Soul Zoe Soul that's I think
she either was in the the last so we know
he was the dude from the last time okay
yeah Michael K Williams that's his effing
name dud that's the guy's name and he did
die recently right I think so I gotta look
dang I can't believe I didn't pull that I'm
pretty sure let me well we can look at it a
different time you guys will tell what's his name
again Michael K Williams that's his name I'll look
it up um whoa that was uh I I am shocked that
this had a significant dip and even the people
in the comments told us that the first Purge is
great he died September 6 2021 yeah sad he he's
been in like every major show that we've loved
um yeah the wire Bravo exactly um oh my God Keith
Stanfield who's that I don't know the one that
you recognized the one that I recognize yeah
what's his when he when he said I'm just doing for
the money oh that's his name I'm pretty sure yeah
really pretty sure oh weird I mean he's great he
was in an Oscar winning fil look Keith but maybe
he just went by Keith I don't know um that was
wild w look what's happening now it's just po oh
it's just for USA watch I thought that that was
still part of it we were just watching water uh
okay obviously we watched the first one together
now you've seen the second one did you do you have
a strong preference um oh yeah good um no I mean
I really don't know why this second one has gotten
bad reviews I mean it looked like when we looked
at the ratings like to click on it to like 58%
and I'm like I like this movie I thought it was
good I thought the first one was really really
great in a way different way and then them taking
us on the road in this one was I mean I found it
just not like the exciting is the wrong word but
I did think that it was an exciting movie that
kept me very engaged because we got to see so many
different parts of the purge that like we did not
get to see in the first movie of people moving
around and what they're doing and I really like
the John Wick like essence of what purge Daddy was
doing of like saving people but really he was on a
mission to kill the guy who killed his son and he
needed those people that he ran into that he saved
to help him along the way like he went through
this journey all night of like recognizing he
he didn't really want to purge him like I think
he he needed those people he needed them in in
his path to make the change which I really like
that story I like that plot line I think it's
good yeah I'm definitely with you this this movie
just felt a lot bigger right the the first movie
was so contained and we're in this house and you
feel claustrophobic in the house right like it's
all about who H can come in the house well the
barriers of the houseold um your neighbors you
know the people that you know can you trust the
people that you know um and what would you do for
a stranger this entire thing was all strangers
and we have the entire world yeah and also kind
of makes you rank bad right like the guy that
was the drunk that breaks into their apartment
yeah because he's been so badly oppressed he's
now become an absolute oppressor during The
Purge right right but that is something that is
a learned behavior from the rich people that are
killing people in the streets right um who are not
at risk in the same way you know like just there's
so many levels of this movie because now we're
seeing how it permeates through entire soci the
the entire Society um the one thing that I I like
it's it's not a nitpick as much as I am curious
with a character like Frank gillow who is out to
for revenge for his son's death right I don't know
if I realistically see him waiting for Purge Night
you know what I mean like I know crime is down but
I don't feel like the reason he would do this is
because now there are no consequences I don't know
if he really gives a [__] about the consequences
you know right um but whatever take that aside I
guess he's like I just have to wait a year because
when when he said it was 12 months 12 months ago I
just assumed it was on that Purge that Purge night
and then he wanted to do payback for that but it's
like it was 12 months ago and you waited for the
night that you wouldn't get in trouble for it I
don't think at that point he cares I think at that
point we're seeing he doesn't have much to live
for left or he believes that obviously does have
a lot to live for right but it didn't distract for
me or detract for me it more just was like huh I
wonder if there is going to be a version of The
Purge I mean right now they started playing the
TV show um we know there are more movies like is
there ever going to be a version where we see what
the purge world is like on non Purge days to see
like how are people interacting it with not with
zero crime apparently and how how does that like
and are the consequences so much worse because
there is Purge day so like if you know you are
caught shoplifting during the year and not on
Purge day are you sentenced to death right are
you like hung or something or like electrocuted
like if you're starving and you take a loaf of
bread then are you killed like because of what
purge day allows so I am curious now this movie
made me really curious about this entire universe
that they've built because we saw more but still
not everything uh and also it unlike the first one
which I still loved but this one really tugged at
my heartstrings in a way that was like because
you're just watching when he said nice to meet
you too uh girl like I I was like it it did kind
of make me emotional because they were both on the
same plane when Michael K Williams character comes
in I said to cie I was like I don't know it just
felt like such a uh like a moment of a of a figure
for her that represented it's not necessarily
good but it kind of is I mean he just kind of came
they're there because they needed to be there it's
the resistance and it's yeah like I think both you
and I think that that's problematic right but also
if you're not if that's what's happening to you
what are you supposed to do what are you gonna do
you might as well like just go the all of these
rich dummies can't just kill us all off like we
have to fight back yeah that was that was a great
moment the other great moment for me is when Frank
gillow does say we're not GNA they're not going to
let us out of here yeah we got to make them earn
it yeah and and everybody kind of looks at him
and they're like okay yep um but also you know
the fact that the I'm a lover of Love shipper
ships the useless girl who wasn't useless in
the end but her her and Shane I was invested in
that love story the mother daughter love story I
was invested in but there were some ends that we
didn't get tied up like I'm devastated about the
grandfather Yeah you know what happens there also
with the money and that I thought that was going
to come into play that now they had that money and
that maybe but ultimately like what good is money
when you don't have your family um so that was a
devastating thing and then what ends up happening
with useless girl we didn't fully tie that up
right no is there a third one yeah definitely
CU everybody in the comments kept telling us
the third one's amazing really cuz I'm like they
brought the guy from the first one back and it was
like a big wow when I recognized him so I'm like
maybe I mean if we got to see that the grandpa
still lived because that group actually saved
him and who also ended up saving his daughter and
his granddaughter there's no way right I'm like
I don't know there's no way I know they they had
knives ready they were already doing their Purge
prayer I definitely saved but I do think that I
would just tape myself up with C4 if I was doing
that I can't believe the thing with the sisters
too yeah like you shot your sister for sleeping
with your husband your sister was sleeping with
your husband also like is that infidelity is that
legal in this universe like or can you only cheat
on the on Purge Night like just so many questions
that was really really well done this the scoring
just was so intense too we talked a little bit
about the um the usage of light in this yeah
it's great really really strong the pops of color
throughout this is like made it so interesting to
watch but it's not pops of color that made it too
distracting of like why would they be running
through an Alleyway and like you would see two
closed garage doors behind them not garage doors
uh storefronts that are closed down but they'd
have like a bright green with like a yellow and
they'd be lit up but it just gave throughout it
there was pops of color in it which I just was not
distracting also made the shots really interesting
I really like that cinematic approach when they
choose like a color scheme of like how are we
going to agre the dialogue wasn't cheesy when it
could have been no it was uh like you said in the
beginning um you were like oh I'm I feel like
it's really natural right you said that right
off the top because because I think in movies
like this it could be like what are we going to
do if they come through that door like you know
and instead of kind of just fell The Testament
into the acting too they do get some unbelievable
actors in here um and it is shot so dark sometimes
it is difficult to recognize people unless you're
Frank gillo in which you are Frank Daddy from jump
um but yeah I just I really like this franchise
it really makes you think it could be trash and
it's excellent for some reason great yeah just
the from the premise to the execution I just
can't get over how they were able to make these
I'm I'm shocked with how much I loved both of
the movies especially after seeing it had like a
50% on Rotten Tomatoes for this what I'm like who
are these people yeah what did you guys want from
a Purge movie if not this I love that the story
lines combined you know that's a big deal for me
um I love how everything kind of merged and felt
organic like it wasn't like it didn't feel too
like uh because it would have if the guy the magga
guy we keep we're calling that but the America
guy it would have felt weird if he had just like
found him and knew but it's because he was like
Sarge I knew where you were headed yeah right and
that's why same thing with when I was like oh is
this where Frank gillo meant to end up like that
would have been too much of a coincidence probably
if he he meant to end up with all the rich people
because they had taken his son or something right
so it was better the way they did it yeah I I this
a good movie yeah a good franchise still just
going like that one Exposition part which we
both were like yeah with the the America guy in
the back of the truck just going like he killed
my friends and my whole team and now I'm here
and those two girls to take them alive he shot
me and now I want him dead but the other two
women I want them alive I'm going to take them
that was the only part that I was like we didn't
really need that I think was he attempting to take
them for the rich people or he wanted to take
them alive I think he wanted no cuz he said for
myself I believe he said I want their mine to kill
them which I'm gross that guy I'm so glad he died
there's so many moments that when the bad people
die the rich people who are the bad people in this
movie when they die It Feels So satisfying like
when the I keep SW when the group that goes in and
they're like time to die rich [__] or something
I and they all go in and kill all those men in
their suits Michael K Williams people yeah I found
it so satisfying and I know it's bad I don't want
like but did I found it very satisfying they
Warriors they're not civilians they are Warrior
like the the I'm talking about the rich people
like they are they've created a rich Army of
people who are murdering yeah so they deserve to
get to die like I would also kill them I would be
like you guys are part of the very big problem but
then the people who are kidnapping and delivering
them also a huge problem but they're attempting
to survive they're not doing it to purge they're
doing it to live and it's like that's still wrong
but a different degree of wrong cuz if it wasn't
if they weren't working for them they would be
bait they would be taken somehow somebody else is
going to take the job right if I was them uh and I
was kidnapping people to bring to the rich people
I would find bad people I would do my research for
the whole year and be like who's messed up bad who
is here and I'm going to kidnap those people the
bad people and take them in cuz they they did some
bad stuff you've got your own Purge movie to write
yeah exactly it'd be like a mix of that jod Foster
movie where she just sits on the subway but she
knows that this guy used to like he did bad stuff
to people and she takes them out and she just does
that with her life it's a great film you guys are
going to leave in the comments be like it's this
film great film it's like a mixture of that that's
what I would do I'd be like I'm going to research
all the bad people I'm going to kidnap you I'm
going to get paid you did some bad juice you
look up like everybody who is at the Insurrection
yeah where you just like find people who have
completely like trash views on women and you're
like okay I'm talking about anybody who's hurt a
friend or like done something to women you all are
[__] like I am taking you kidnapp you I'm going
to hurt you a little bit first like you people who
got off after like six months of baby you're mine
now that's the people I'd capture for the Brock
Turners of the world yeah I hear you I think that
that's a good idea but also like I don't think
that they're able to really they're grabbing who
they can grab easy from the street right although
the the one thing is that they did set up Matt
saris and and uh useless they set them up because
remember they bumped into them at the store so it
was like then set up the bad people that's what
I mean I'm like just like I I mean if you know
you're going to do that on that night I would just
be like we need to do some research and find out
where these bad people live and then let's just
capture them right and call call it a night let's
get all the bad people that Keith Stanfield but
he goes by Keith Stanfield or was it not well I'll
look at you guys will tell us in the comments yeah
they'll let us know um all right well Purge Purge
Purge just gonna do that for every reaction now
any final Purge thoughts anything else you want
to purge I loved it I don't know what these people
are talking about when they're like it's a it's
a dud it's a it's a great film I liked everything
about it the way it's shot the lighting the music
it's great choices great acting I was never out
of it thinking this person I don't believe him I
believed all of them so we want to watch the third
one so make sure you like comment subscribe can
we get a post ring that Bell does it only happen
once ring that bell ring the bell purch all that
good stuff so that we can come back here thank you
guys for watching Purge Anarchy and for being
absolute Anarchist with us Purge bye [Music]